is all about politics we've been told
this is going to start on the dot
and indeed it is a different look
sir chris whittie on the right and
patrick valance the chief scientific
advisor on the left
we wanted to give you an update on where
we see the epidemic at the moment
some of the knowns and some of the
uncertainties
let me just start by reminding you that
this disease spreads
by droplets by surface contact and by
aerosols
hence the hands-face space but also to
remind you
that the way that we reduce the spread
is by limiting our number of contacts
by reducing contact in environments
where spread is more likely
those are crowded environments indoor
environments
poor ventilation and making sure that we
reduce the probability
of coming into contact with anyone who
is infectious and that's the importance
of self-isolation keeping out of
circulation
if you have or may have the virus
may have the first slide please
i want to start by talking about the
rise in cases elsewhere and what we can
learn
we've seen increased in cases across
europe
and here i've taken examples of spain
and france
we've seen an increase in the numbers of
cases it started
with younger people in their 20s and
spread gradually
to older ages as well that
increase in case number has translated
into an increase in hospitalizations
as the hospitalizations have increased
as you look at the slide on the right
here you will see that very sadly but
not unexpectedly
deaths are also increasing
so there's a simple message from this
slide which is that
as the disease spreads as it spreads
across
age groups we expect to see
increase in hospitalizations and
unfortunately
those increase in hospitalizations will
lead to an increase in deaths the virus
has genetically moved a bit but it has
not changed
in terms of its propensity and its
ability to cause disease
and to cause death even though of course
most of the disease deaths occur in
the older population so where are we
here
next slide please
these are data from testing and i'll
come back to that point in a minute
and their data for england but the
picture is fairly similar across the uk
and and
chris whittie will say more about that
what we see
from july as we look at the increase in
cases
per hundred thousand of population an
increase which has
occurred over august and has increased
into september
this is by different age groups and the
top line the blue line
is amongst the 20 to 29 year olds
but what you can see is there's been an
increase in cases across
all age groups the
lowest increase has been in children and
in the
population age 70 to 79 but in every age
group we've seen an increase
could that increase be due to increased
testing the answer is no
we see an increase in positivity of the
test done so we see the proportion of
people testing positive has increased
even if testing stays flat
and if we look at other sources of data
such as for example the ons
study which takes a sample of people
across the population looks at it or
studies like the react study
we see a similar increase in the ons
study
it's now estimated that roughly seventy
thousand
people in the uk have covered infection
and that about six thousand people per
day
are getting the infection so we are in a
situation
where numbers are clearly increasing
they're increasing across all age groups
it's a little bit different in different
areas
in terms of geographies and chris will
speak to that
and this increase in numbers is also
translating
into an increase in hospitalization
which chris will say more about
so there's no doubt we're in a situation
where the numbers increasing
what i'd like to do is just remind you
how quickly this can move
so the next slide is not a prediction
but it is a way of thinking about how
quickly this can change
so this is the uk reported cases per day
against time and you can see running
along the bottom there
the number of cases over june july
and august up to roughly 3 000 cases per
day or so
in september middle of september
at the moment we think that the epidemic
is doubling roughly every seven days
it could be a little bit longer maybe a
little bit shorter but let's say roughly
every seven days
if and that's quite a big if but if that
continues
unabated and this grows
doubling every seven days then what you
see
of course let's say there were five
thousand today it would be ten thousand
next week twenty thousand a week after
forty thousand the week after
and you can see that by mid-october if
that continued
you would end up with something like 50
000 cases
in the middle of october per day
50 000 cases per day would be expected
to lead a month later so the middle of
november say
to 200 plus deaths per day
so this graph which is not a prediction
is simply showing you
how quickly this can move if the
doubling time
stays at seven days and of course the
challenge therefore
is to make sure the doubling time does
not stay at seven days
there already things in place which are
expected to slow that
and to make sure that we do not enter
into this exponential growth
and end up with the problems that you
would predict as a result of that
that requires speed it requires action
and it requires enough in order to be
able to bring that down
one final word on this
section so as we see it
cases are increasing hospitalizations
are following deaths unfortunately will
follow that
and there is the potential for this to
move very fast
a word on immunity next slide please
when people have an infection the vast
majority of people
get an antibody response and we know
that some of those antibodies are
so-called neutralizing antibodies they
do indeed protect against the virus
we also know that they fade over time
and there are cases of people becoming
reinfected
so this is not an absolute protection
and it will potentially decrease over
time
what we see is that something under
eight percent of the population
have been infected as we measure the
antibodies
so about eight percent so three million
or so people
may have been infected and have
antibodies
it means that the vast majority of us
are not protected in any way
and are susceptible to this disease
there may be other forms of protection
that increase that number a little bit
other parts of the immune system but it
does mean
that the vast majority of the population
remains susceptible
and therefore you'd expect spread
throughout them the number of people
with antibodies is a little higher in
the cities and it may be as high as 17
percent or so in london
that may confer a little slowing of
spread but not much more than that
at that point i'll pass over to chris to
take you through some of the other
features of the
epidemic chris thanks battery next slide
please
so what we have here are two maps
they're from england but there would be
similar ones
uh from scotland wales or northern
ireland and what we have on the left
uh here is a map where the darker colors
are the rate of transmission and on the
right what we have is a map where orange
or yellow or brown represent an
increasing rate of transmission the
darker that color
the greater the rate of increase and
green
or blue represent
a stable or falling situation and what
you can see
in on the left side is that at the
moment
the very high rates of transmission in
the uk are highly concentrated
in particular areas but there are
significant rates of transmission
in many parts of the uk with the darker
colours
but what we've seen is a progression
where after the remarkable efforts which
got the rates right down across the
country
firstly we saw very small outbreaks
might be associated with the workplace
or
another environment then we've seen more
localized
outbreaks which have got larger over
time particularly in the cities
and now what we're seeing is a rate of
increase
across the great majority of the country
it's going at different rates but it is
now
increasing and what we found is that as
the rate as it
as we go through in time uh anywhere
which
was falling is now moving over to
beginning to rise
and then the rate of rise uh continues
in an upward direction
so this is not someone else's problem
this is all of our problem
next slide please
this graph is a simple one it simply
shows
the number of inpatient cases in england
over the period from the 1st of august
and until that point in time there had
been a steady fall
over a long period of time right back
from
early april and it then stabilized for a
period and flattened out
but over the period since the 1st of
september
you can see a steady sustained rise in
numbers
with a doubling time as with the cases
of probably seven or eight days
now what that tells us is that if this
carried on unabated these numbers are
relatively small
we're talking about around 200 at the
moment
but if this if we continued along the
path that patrick
laid out the number of deaths directly
from covid i'll come back to indirect
deaths
will continue to rise potentially on an
exponential curve that means doubling
and doubling and doubling again
and you can quickly move from really
quite small numbers
to really very large numbers because of
that exponential process
so we have in a bad sense literally
turned a corner
although only relatively recently
and we i think everybody will realize
that at this point the seasons are
against us
we're now going into the seasons late
autumn and winter
which benefit respiratory viruses and it
is very likely
they will benefit uh kovid as they do
for example
flu so we should see this as a
six-month uh problem that we have to
deal with collectively
it's not indefinite and as i come on to
science will in due course
can't ride to our rescue but in this
period of the next six months
i think we have to realize that we have
to take this collectively very seriously
a lot of people have said maybe this is
a milder virus
than it was in april i'm afraid although
that would be great if that were true we
see no evidence that is the case
at the moment because the cases started
to rise
most in the lowest
age bands in young adults not in
children children
the rates have really not increased as
the data patrick showed
show to young children but in young
adults these are the groups who are
least likely to end up in hospital and
a point we made right from the beginning
is that for many people
this remains a mild infection but as you
move up the ages if you move into people
who are more vulnerable then the
mortality rates if people get this
rise to quite significant rates and what
we've seen
in other countries and are now clearly
seeing here
is that they're not staying just in the
younger age groups
they're moving up the age bands and the
mortality rates
will be similar to slightly lower than
they were previously but they will be
similar to
what we saw previously and these are
significantly greater for example
than ordinary seasonal flu so um
seasonal flu normally
in the uk would on average year kill
around 7000
people a year tragically and in a bad
flu year as there was for example about
three years ago
uh it might kill uh upward of twenty
thousand a a year
uh this uh virus is more virulent uh
than
flu so the numbers uh people talk about
are not unreasonable
uh numbers for us to be thinking about
treatment is better there's no doubt
about that doctors
nurses have learned to treat this much
more effectively and we have new drugs
such as dexamethasone these will reduce
the mortality rate
but they will definitely not eliminate
or take it right down to trivial levels
two other broad points i wanted to make
the first one
is that there are as we've said from the
beginning and it really
does need to be repeated four ways in
which this virus is going to have
a very potential significant effect on
the population's health if we let it go
out of control
the first the easiest to to identify is
direct
covert deaths people who get the virus
and die of the virus
the second would be if the nhs emergency
services
were overwhelmed by a huge spike and
that is what
the extraordinary efforts of the
population allowed to prevent happening
in the first wave we met
the third however is very important and
i think uh its importance should not be
understated which is if the nhs is
having to spend a large proportion of
its effort
uh in trying to treat covert cases
because the numbers are going up very
hot to a very high levels
and trying to put in case in place large
numbers of uh systems to try and reduce
the risk of transmission in hospitals
it will lead to a reduction in treatment
for other areas
in early diagnosis of disease and in
prevention programs
beca and so there is an indirect effect
on deaths and on illness
from this impact on the nhs if we allow
the numbers
to rise too fast but on the other side
we also know that some of the things
we've had to do
are going to cause significant problems
on in the economy
big social impacts impacts on mental
health
and therefore ministers making decisions
and all of
society have to walk this very difficult
balance
if we do too little this virus will go
out of control
and we will get significant numbers of
increased direct and indirect deaths
but if we go too far the other way then
we can cause damage
uh to the economy which can feed through
to unemployment to poverty
uh to deprivation all of which have
long-term health effects so
we need always to keep these two sides
in mind
my final point is that if i increase my
risk
a lot of people say well can't people
just be allowed to take their own risk
the problem with a pandemic or an
epidemic infection like this
is if i as an individual increase my
risk i increase the risk
to everyone around me and then everyone
who's a contact to theirs
and sooner or later the chain will meet
people who are vulnerable or elderly or
have a long
term problem from covid so you cannot in
an epidemic
just take your own risk unfortunately
you're taking a
risk on behalf of everybody else it's
important that
we see this as something we have to do
collectively and there are broadly
four things we can do over the next
period to get on top of this
the first of which is reducing our
individual risk
and this is around the things that we
all know about
hands face space washing hands using
masks particularly in
environments which are enclosed in
public transport and so on
and also in particular having space
between people whenever we can achieve
it
especially when indoors the second group
of things are things we can do to
isolate the virus so if people have
symptoms they must self-isolate
and we must find their contacts so that
they can isolate
and in people who've traveled from
high-risk areas they also should isolate
and this means
that they are taking on behalf of
society a
big step forward to keep the virus out
of circulation whilst they are still
infectious
this is an absolutely critical part of
the response
the third one and in many ways the most
difficult
uh is that we have to break unnecessary
links between households
because that is the way in which this
virus is transmitted
and this means reducing social contacts
whether they are at work
and this is where we have enormous
gratitude to all the businesses
for example who worked so hard to make
their environments covered secure to
reduce the risk
and also in social environments
and we have to try and do this in the
least damaging way but we
we all know we cannot do this without
some
significant downsides and this is this
is a balance of risk
between if we don't do enough the virus
will take off and we at the moment
that is the path that we are clearly on
and we if we do not change course then
we are going to find ourselves in a very
difficult problem
as patrick has laid out the final thing
we can do
is the science is investing in drugs
vaccines diagnostics and patrick is
going to take us through as the final
section
where we've got to with the most
exciting of these which is vaccines
thank you very much as chris has said we
will be living with these facts
this virus this is now circulating
amongst the population worldwide
it will continue to do so we will be
learning how to live with it
one important part of that is vaccines
i'm pleased to say that there is good
progress that's been made
many vaccines now have shown they
generate an immune response
of a type that ought to be protective
and several vaccines
are in very late stage clinical testing
aiming to show that they are both
effective and
safe the uk through the vaccines task
force
has got access to a number of these as
illustrated on this slide
with a range of different vaccine
technologies
from a number of different companies
the uk therefore has put itself in a
good position
in terms of vaccine supply and the
possibility that one of these will work
we don't yet know that they will work
but there is increasing evidence that
it's pointed in the right direction
and it's possible that some vaccine
could be available before the end of the
year in small amounts
for certain groups much more likely that
we'll see vaccines becoming available
over the first half of next year again
not certain
but pointed in the right direction which
then of course gives the possibility
of a different approach to this virus
but in the meantime
we've got to get on control control of
this in the way that chris has described
in order to make sure that we can live
with it in a way that's sustainable
and protects health and society overall
thank you very much